[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
are going to be taking a look at the
most popular theories about secret
family connections between some of the
characters in my hero academia this
includes a theory about Todoroki having
a secret brother and a theory about the
true identity of decos father along with
a few other theories some of these
theories have been circulating online
for quite a while and others I kind of
stumbled upon in my own research so I
thought it would be a good idea to
examine them here and to see whether any
of them could possibly be true there
will of course be manga spoilers in this
video so proceed with caution but I want
to emphasize that the theories
themselves are not spoilers because
there is no concrete evidence for them
being true in the canonical material for
now all of this is just speculation and
I'm not trying to convince you to accept
any of these theories I am just
exploring the arguments themselves and
whether they make any logical sense feel
free to let me know what you think about
these theories down in the comments and
if you have more theories of your own
definitely share them below and before
we get started I just want to say that
we have a lot of my hero academia videos
on the channel here already and many
more are on the way so if you are new
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and if you want to
discuss my ear academia theories with a
whole bunch of other fans you can join
our discord server link in the
description and without further ado the
first secret family connection theory is
that short thought father akhi and the
villain Dobby could be brothers well
this may sound crazy at first it is
quite a popular theory among fans and
while I thought it was kind of
ridiculous when I first heard about it
after giving it some thought I think
that this one might actually be possible
dobby is a villain who was inspired by
stains ideology to join up with the
league of villains because he mistakenly
believed that stain was affiliated with
before the appearance of staying Dobby
was just a petty criminal but stains
ideals inspired him to take his villainy
to the next level something I always
found very interesting about Dobby is
that he refuses to reveal his real name
when he first meets shigaraki the two of
them nearly kill each other because
Shiva rocky feels that Dhabi's refusal
to reveal his name is disrespectful it
is only because of kuru giddy
intervening that they did not end up
using their deadly quirks on each other
and this got me thinking why is Dobby so
committed to hiding his real name could
it be that his family name is famous in
the world of my hero academia and so on
the other villains knew his name
it would hurt his reputation could it be
that his real family name is Todoroki
because he is the son of ng Todoroki the
former number two and current number
one-ranked pro hero and ever
we know that endeavor only married show
toes mother because of her quirk
obsessed with surpassing almighty power
and never decided that he had to create
an offspring with an incredibly powerful
quirk we also know that Shoto has an
older sister and two older brothers but
it wasn't until shota was born that had
never finally felt that he had a child
with a quirk that is strong enough to
one day surpass all might while we have
already seen shota sister we have not
seen his older brothers and we don't
know their names
so could Dobby be one of these two older
brothers he does have a fire based work
just like Endeavour although his flames
are darker in appearance but is it
possible that Dobby is sholto's older
brother who after seeing Endeavour abuse
their mother to the point that she was
committed to a mental institution
decided to run away from home
reject the hero society and adopt
staines philosophy because stain hates
vain and egotistical pro heroes like
Endeavour
may be but one striking difference
between Dobby and short oh and shuttles
older sister is that while they both
have red and white hair like their
parents and Deborah's hair is red
his wife's hair is white of course Davi
has dark black hair the other problem is
that if Dobby was really one of the
siblings Todoroki grew up with someone
would likely have recognized him during
the school trip and hideout raid arks if
Davi is total Rocky's brother I think he
would likely be his half-brother a child
of Endeavour and another woman perhaps
from a previous marriage or relationship
in that case Dobby could have inherited
his dark hair and the dark color of his
flames from this other woman and if he
was a child from a previous relationship
that he likely would have never met Soto
or his other siblings one thing that I
think makes this a real possibility is
endeavour's own personality if he had
been in a relationship with another
woman and Dobby was their child
I think endeavour is definitely the type
of person to abandon Dobby if he felt
that Dobby was unworthy of one day
surpassing all mine
if Dobby was born with his unique
features that include purple flesh
stitches and scars I don't doubt for a
second that endeavour would think of him
as inferior and abandon him the fact
that endeavour chose sholto's mom
specifically because of her strong quirk
could mean that he tried having children
before and this experience taught him
that he must handpick his partner and
make sure she has the strongest possible
quirk otherwise he will not be able to
achieve the desired results as was
potentially the case with Dobby and if
Dobby was abandoned by his father as a
child and his father then went on to
become one of the top-ranked and most
famous bro heroes it would make perfect
sense for him to despise the giro
society and to sympathize with stains
ideology which of course condemns people
like Endeavour Dobby would be ashamed of
his biological connection to Endeavour
and so it would also make perfect sense
for him to hide his real name there is
of course no way for us to prove this
from the information we have so far but
personally I think this would be a
really cool and very interesting twist
to the story and a great way to develop
both Dobby and show total rookie as
characters
in the future and what do you guys think
will this theory turn out to be true let
me know down below
another huge mystery in the world of my
hero academia is the identity of Dec
whose father we know that his real name
is Hisashi midoriya
and that he works outside of japan which
is why we never see him in the story we
also know that dec whose father has a
quirk that allows him to breathe fire
because dec whose mom reveals this
information to us in the first chapter
of the manga and the first episode of
the anime now this revelation about dec
whose father having a fire based quirk
has led a lot of people to speculate
that dec whose real father might
actually be ng Todoroki aka and ever by
the way if all of these theories about
Endeavour are correct I think he might
be getting his own spin-off harem anime
sometime in the future I wonder what the
title for that spin-off would be
something like flame hero harem I don't
know let me know what title you would
give to an endeavour harem spin-off in
the comments personally I don't think
that this theory about endeavour being
Decker's father and Deku being shot owes
brother is true for one we know
endeavours quark isn't to breathe fire
but rather to generate and manipulate
powerful flames so I don't see why that
coos mom would say breathe fire instead
of simply mentioned the full extent of
his work the other reason is that we
have to remember that in the world of my
hero academia endeavour is famous and he
has been famous for years there is no
way that no one would mention endeavour
being dec whose dad if this information
was known by deku and other people and
of course it doesn't make sense that
that was dad's name is he sashimi Daria
if he was actually Angie Todoroki the
only way that this theory could possibly
be true is a BEC who never even met his
dad and his mom Inc Oh basically lied to
everyone including Deku about his
father's identity in that case he
Tsushima Daria doesn't really have a job
abroad he doesn't even exist and he was
completely made up by dec whose mom to
hide the fact that she had hooked up
with endeavour sometime in the past I
just don't think the dec whose mom is
the type of person to lie and to manip
late hearse on his whole life in this
way and I certainly don't think that
that who would believe he has a father
abroad but has never seen him or even
spoken to him on the phone so for this
theory
I am definitely unknown another theory
that I thought of while looking at some
of your comments on our videos stems
from the fact that the 18-plus
only hero midnight has a very similar
quirk to the teenage villain mustard who
is a member of the main guard action
squad midnight's quirk is called
somnambulist and it enables her to
generate a sleep-inducing smell from her
body and anyone who breathes the smell
in will fall asleep
mustard squirt sleep gas does
essentially the same thing as midnight
squirt except his gas is also toxic and
can do internal damage to its target if
the target is exposed to it for a long
time mustard is also not immune to his
own work and he has to wear a gas mask
whereas midnight does not because her
quirk does not affect her
however these quirks are still very
similar and we know that in the world of
my hero academia similar quirks are
often possessed by members of the same
family so for example Colton his parents
all had water-based quirks
so Totoro key inherited the ice and fire
aspects of both of his parents quirks
and sujes family all have frog based
works and so on so could the similarity
in their quirks mean that midnight and
mustard are somehow related again this
is complete speculation but we know that
midnight is 31 years old we don't know
much about mustard except that he is a
teenager and probably a high school
student so could it be possible that
midnight had a child when she was very
young maybe 15 or 16 years old and then
gave him up for adoption because she was
too young to raise him today that child
would be about mustards age and if
midnight was mustards estranged mother
then it would explain why he seems to
have a hatred for you a and you a
students if mustard knows that his
mother abandoned him and is now a pro
hero and a you a teacher
it would certainly
playing his resentment for dua and for
pro heroes in general and it would be a
compelling reason for him to become a
villain so what do you think is the
similarity between their quirks just a
coincidence or are mustard and
Midnight's somehow related finally we
have a theory that I first proposed in
my video about Tamura shigaraki and this
theory states that shigaraki and all for
one the mastermind behind the league of
villains might actually be related by
blood we know that all mites quark one
for all dates back to two brothers the
older brother is all for one and he had
a quirk that allowed him to steal quirks
from other people and either use them
himself or transfer them to others
all-4-one transferred a quirk that
stockpiles power onto his younger
brother because the under brother did
not have a quark that anyone knew but in
fact the younger brother did have a
hidden quark which allowed him to
transfer quirks from himself onto
someone else this is how the quark
one-for-all was created a combination of
the stockpiling power quark and the
hidden quark that gives the ability to
pass works down to others the older
brother
all-4-one eventually became the most
powerful villain in japan and the
younger brother decided that he would
oppose his brother's evil plans the
younger brother was not able to defeat
all four one on his own but he
transferred his quark to the next
generation until finally all might that
eight user of one-for-all was able to
defeat all four one but what if this
idea of next generation isn't just
referring to transferring the curve to a
random person what if it means
transferring it to literally the next
generation within your own family what
if one for all was transferred from
generation to generation within the
shamone family all the way up until Nana
Shimura decided to give her son into
foster care and transferred a quark to
Toshi noriaki aka all might instead we
know that this is possible because all
for one is indeed very old since he
appears to have stolen a quark that
allows him to live for
many generations and if this is the case
that shigaraki would have an additional
reason to hate all my all might receive
the quirk that was supposed to be passed
on to him through his own family if this
were the case it would explain a few
other things in the story for instance I
always felt that the younger brother in
the story above one for all and all for
one looks a lot like she got a keeper
also this would explain why all four one
cares so much about shigaraki thought of
all people all for one continues to
believe in and encourage shigaraki
throughout the series despite shiitakes
many failures and in chapter 89 we find
out that all four one even plans to find
a new quark 4 shigaraki
that would suit his personality
all-4-one says to shigaraki
everything is for your sake all for one
even ends up getting arrested because he
wanted to make sure that she kuraki and
the other villains could escape in
chapter 91 so he stays behind to keep
all my busy it really does not seem like
she kuraki is just another random
recruit - all for one it is almost as if
they were family and if she got a key is
directly descended from all four ones
brother do Nana and the other shamone
generations the two of them would in
fact be directly connected by blood and
that is it guys four theories about
secret family connections in the world
of my hero academia let me know what you
think about these theories and whether
you have a theory of your own as I
mentioned earlier feel free to disagree
with these theories it is all just
speculation and we can't know for sure I
do have another theory about a possible
secret family connection of the you a
traitor
but I might make a separate video above
the UI trader in the future so if you
would like to see that video be sure to
leave a like and let me know in the
comments we have a lot of minor academia
videos here on the channel already and
many more are on the way so if you are
new don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell and if you want
to discuss my ear academia theories with
a whole bunch of other fans you can join
our discord server link in the
description as always thank you
much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]